pour à tous merci de nous suivre en
direct sur figaro live dans quelques
minutes mais maintenant on doit avoir
lieu la passation de pouvoir entre
angela merkel la chancelière allemande
et son successeur olaf scholz on la voit
en gala merkel sur ces images diffusées
en direct
olaf scholz qui va la remplacer s'est
présenté ce matin à la candidature au
poste de chancelier devant les 736
membres du bundestag qui l'ont adoubée
il a ensuite reçu son acte officiel de
nominations au siège de la présidence de
la république avant de prêter serment
sur la constitution ou parlement c'est
ainsi que débute donc ce 8 décembre et
pour quatre années le mandat du 9e
chancelier de la république fédérale
allemande pour commenter cet événement
politique et historique nous sommes en
direct en plateau avec nous avec nicolas
barotte ex correspondant à
berlin pardon pour le figaro bonjour
nicolas bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et d'être en direct
avec nous pour qu'on peut on pour
commenter cette passation de pouvoir
entre angela merkel et donc son
successeur olaf scholz merci à vous de
nous suivre en direct et de nous poser
toutes les questions qui vous viennent
et vos commentaires sur le site figaro
l'arrivée sur notre chaîne youtube et
nicolas l'arrivée du nouveau chancelier
allemand au pouvoir marque la fin des
seize années au pouvoir de l'air ang et
la merkel comment les allemands vivent
cet événement politique et historique et
le départ de cette chancelière qui a
fait partie on peut le dire de leur
quotidien pendant 16 ans bien sûr
c'était une incarnation de l'allemagne
avec son son passé n'est pas vécue en
rda dont une figure angela merkel et
elle part étant très populaire les
sondages sont à 80% et quelques elle est
vraiment encore au zénith et pourquoi
pas ce qu est l après paraître départ
depuis depuis longtemps donc totalement
son sont habitués préparer en fait
qu'elle s'en aille depuis 2010 elle a
dit qu'elle ne serait pas candidate à sa
succession
parce qu'il ya aussi une part en amène
de lassitude il a oublié mais en 2017 il
ya beaucoup de lassitude envers ses amis
merkel marqué par beaucoup d'inertie et
donc le changement est bienvenue aussi
même si les allemands ils disent au
revoir parce que l âme qui est
effectivement une époque elle a marqué
une époque en allemagne alors qu'on voit
olaf scholz donc son successeur qui
vient de remettre à angela merkel un
bouquet de fleurs et il vient de prendre
la parole si on peut la voir légèrement
en font
olaf scholz pendant que on échange avec
nicolas barotte
à nicolas il va falloir se familiariser
un désormais avec avec le visage et la
personnalité de la folle quand on lit le
papier de pierre avril ce matin dans le
quotidien il parle d'un personnage terne
et une arrivée surprise au sommet de la
4e puissance mondiale et première
puissance économique européenne qui est
donc ce monsieur olaf scholz et comment
est parvenu à s'imposer et à succéder à
angela merkel alors c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup du manque de charisme
dans gala merkel avait créé la fiole tu
ne seras pas déçu ce sera la même chose
voire pire c'est un personnage qui est
très rare vie très peu expressif qui est
dans la droite du spd donc pas de
grandes envolées lyriques pas de grandes
ruptures c'est un homme du continuité
d'ailleurs lui-même de rabdhure a duré
la campagne disait je peux être
chancelière voilà donc qui s'inscrit
n'allait pas dedans gala mercian alors
il est là un peu par hasard soyons
honnêtes parce que il ya
2 ans et 4 le spd était au fond du trou
et personne n'aurait imaginé qu'il
puisse remporter les élections mais la
faiblesse du candidat d'être cédées ou
remises n'achète les erreurs des verts
aussi c'était un temps donné comme
potentiel
candidat crédible à jean cédric ont
permis à la chose ils ont esquissé la
continuité la stabilité de frayer un
passage mais quand on voit les chiffres
avec 25% le s&p est arrivé assez bas
comme il avait pu l'être dans les années
précédentes si vous nous rejoignez
maintenant on dirait que sur figaro
l'arrivée sur notre chaîne youtube nous
sommes en train de vous faire vivre la
passation de pouvoir entre angela merkel
la chancelière allemande qui quitte le
pouvoir après 16 années passées à la
tête de l'allemagne on va dire elle est
remplacée par le monsieur que vous voyez
à l'image qui est en train de s'exprimer
en direct depuis la chancellerie à
berlin en allemagne c'est au lave olaf
scholz aux pattes devoir se familiariser
avec la prononciation de son nom avec
qui son image également son physique
nicolas barotte est avec nous c'est l'ex
correspondant du figaro à berlin il
répond à vos questions si vous en avez
vous pouvez les poser en direct olaf
scholz donc prend la tête du
gouvernement aujourd'hui officiellement
il ya deux choses inédites le concernant
il prend la tête d'un gouvernement
paritaire c'est la première fois entre
hommes et femmes et il prend également
la tête d'une coalition qui était
inédite dans l'histoire politique
allemande puisque elle associe trois
parties alors que la parité cette
importance à voile après raisonnée
merkel ne pas remplacer une fin par une
équipe d'hommes évidemment et après
effectivement être collées sur a3 c'est
totalement inédit dans la république
fédérale d'allemagne et ça pose beaucoup
de questions comment vont cohabiter
trois parties aussi différents fai se
souvient qu'en 2010 est déjà les verts
les libéraux font l époque peut-être cdu
avait essayé de former une coalition ce
n'est pas fonctionné parce que les
différences étaient trop grandes et sans
doute que les prix n'étaient pas mûrs à
l'époque aujourd'hui une vraie volonté
une envie des verts comme des libéraux
nous gouverner donc il ya une
responsabilité pour faire tenir la
coalition maintenant c'est déjà très
compliquée à 2 de tenir un gouvernement
en allemagne à 300 encore plus donc il y
aura pas beaucoup de fantaisie par
rapport à ce qui était écrit dans le
contrat de coalition qui est très précis
mais on aura du mal en allemagne en
débordés
alors qu'elle va être qu'elle va être
parent dont le programme la feuille de
route que veut conduire désormais olaf
scholz alors justement à cause de coups
et blessures il ya deux grands axes
importants et la transition
environnementale
parce qu'en plus l'allemagne prioritaire
cette transition il est prioritaire dont
plus que les allemands ont un vrai
retard en termes d'émissions de co2
parce qu'ils ont fait le choix de sortir
du nucléaire justement c'est un gala
merkel qui va décider en 2011 donc ça va
relancer les sons à charbon explique son
et qui produisent beaucoup de charbon
donc il ya un vrai effort à faire à ce
niveau là pour respecter des engagements
deuxième axe c'est la transition
digitales numériques qui est très cher
aux libéraux elle a aussi un il ya un
retard qui tient un peu au
sous-investissement
allemand chronique et qui font rattraper
5e en allemagne
tout ce qui est numérique n'est pas
avant c'est bon aussi développée qu'on
peut l'imaginer par rapport à
l'industrie est là il y aura un effort
et après il ya beaucoup de mesures
symboliques on a vu le cannabis par
exemple oui qui seront aussi portés pour
donner des marqueurs identifié à la
collision mais chaude sera de continuité
donc il va continuer on va dire la
politique d'angela merkel en matière de
politique étrangère maintenant on sait
que la question est importante elle nous
concerne de près nous la france olaf
scholz défend une europe plus souveraine
c'est ce qu'il a dit il fait d'ailleurs
son premier déplacement à l'étranger ce
vendredi à paris pour participer au
sommet sur l'ukraine avec le président
de la république emmanuel macron
qu'elles vont être justement les
relations entre l'allemagne et la france
désormais il ya beaucoup d'attentes 5e
engrais merkel avait un peu déçu quand
même paris parce que les français et
même à contre beaucoup d'autres
chancelière qu'elle porte un projet
européen notamment impression de
discours à leur service en 2017 ce
qu'elle n'a pas pu faire pour des
raisons de politique interne et pour des
raisons aussi 32 de prudence personnel à
ce que shot fera plus sans doute qu'il
est [ __ ] une volonté justement de
rattraper ce retard et donc les mots qui
pendant sera à paris va être surveillé
parce que pour macron tout ce qui les
unit stratégiste important pour l'europe
de la défense c'est pas sûr que
l'allemagne ait sur ce terrain là même
si on parle de souveraineté européenne
cette importante donc il ya une
évolution maintenant faut pas se leurrer
c'est que
vision européenne de l'allemagne pas
forcément celle de la france absolument
que les projets allemands européens qui
sont par groupe fédéral peut être plus
fort que précédemment ça veut pas dire
que ce seront ceux de paris non faut
être prudent calmes dans
l'interprétation il ya beaucoup de
chantiers à régler et on y en avoir en
tête aussi que sortie à la crise de la
pandémie on va devoir revenir à une
politique aussi économique européenne et
la stabilité se resserrait critère
important pour les allemands et pour les
libéraux et quand on voit les déficits
français et allemands et européens on
sent bien que à moyen terme il y aura un
sujet qui se posera entre paris et berne
et donc pour reprendre une formule je
crois de philippe gélis matin dans son
édito une allemagne plus européenne ça
n'est pas forcément une europe plus
allemande en tout cas il faudra éviter
que ça le soit vous parliez du nucléaire
tout à l'heure nicolas barotte c'est
aussi un sujet qui peut fâcher entre la
france et l'allemagne oui bien sûr c'est
très symbolique trek des allemands à
l'adie sont sortie du nucléaire emmanuel
macron veut relancer le nucléaire pour
des raisons environnementales et
écologiques
avec les verts dans la coalition il y
aura un débat à une question a amené et
se démode taxonomie c'est un peu
compliqué mais ça fait beaucoup parler à
bruxelles est ce que le nucléaire doit
rentrer ou pas dans la taxonomie c'est
très compliqué mais ce sera un sujet dur
que les présidents et chancelier devront
aborder très vite parce qu'à la france
donc à la présidence de l'union
européenne à partir de janvier et macron
voudra avancer très vite avant
l'élection présidentielle
on est quelques-uns nous suivre en
direct sur figaro live et sur notre
chaîne youtube et certains d'entre vous
fondez font des commentaires sur sur
cette passation de pouvoir est sur le
départ définitif d'angela merkel de la
présidence de la chancellerie de
allemande on la voit en gala merkel qui
se voit remettre de nouveau un un
bouquet de fleurs aujourd'hui une
quelques minutes plus tôt c'est son
successeur olaf scholz qui le lui a
killer remis également un bouquet angela
merkel donc s'en va son successeur prend
la relève officiellement aujourd'hui
on a quelques commentaires à son sujet 4
brive sur le chat youtube du figaro nous
dit bravo à un gala merkel pour son beau
parcours bonne continuation à elle
bon vent également nous ajoute un autre
internaute alors qu'on voit voilà ce
cérémonial simple pour le départ de
danger dans gala merkel qu'est ce
qu'elle va devenir angela merkel nicolas
barotte est-ce qu'elle va continuer à se
montrer en politique à intervenir où
elle quitte et largue les amarres
totalement c'est très compliqué ça que
très longtemps on lui a prêté des
ambitions européennes internationales
etc elle a toujours dit qu'il n'était
pas question et je dors mal se tient à
ce qu'elle lit
avant de partir avant de quitter ses
fonctions elle a dit qu'elle aspirait à
voir du repos c'est ce qu'elle a dit
qu'elle voulait prendre un livre lire s
endormir et c'est quelle affaire sans
doute parce que c'est une femme qui a su
rester simple durant tout son mandat et
pas de vent ça change elle tient à
conserver une vie normale et elle va
aspirer un peu de repos maintenant la
pression sera forte sur elle pour
qu'elle exerce aussi une responsabilité
pour qu'ils aient pour qu'elle ait un
discours parce que en iran pendant 16
ans gouverner d'allemagne ne négligera
pas s'abstenir d'intervenir elle ne
parle pas elle sera sollicitée et sont
donc impossible qu'elle a des
convictions malgré tout elle voudra
participer au débat et donner son
éclairage pas sous des formes de
conférences rémunéré passe le déforme de
responsabilité sans doute mais elle ne
disparaîtra pas du paysage hier lire un
bureau à berlin des collaborateurs pour
pouvoir travailler alors qu'on voit
justement gala merkel qui quitte la
chancellerie
où vient d'avoir lieu la passation
physique officiel entre angela merkel ex
chancelière allemande et son successeur
olaf scholz on vient de voir ces images
avec remise de bouquets de fleurs de
part et d'autre et les drapeaux
évidemment allemands et européens on
vient d'évoquer l'europe avec nicolas
barotte merci beaucoup nicolas barotte
pour vos éclairages et votre expertise
sur le sujet merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis pour cette passation donc vécu en
direct depuis berlin en allemagne vous
nous retrouver évidemment dès que
l'occasion se présente en direct sur nos
chaînes figaro life lefigaro.fr et sur
youtube je vous dis à très vite